You don't ever have to buy meat in
Australia? No. No. Do you ever buy meat?
If we're eating chicken, yeah, that's
about it. But just to mix it up. Yeah.
The fridge is full. I feel only
friends, fridges, me, families, fridges.
So funny chicken. What's that? Mountain
lion tastes like fucking delicious.
That's what I keep hearing.
It's delicious and people get angry.
It's so strange to me how angry people
get if you kill a mountain line. Yeah.
Cause I think they think
that if you kill it,
it's different than killing a deer or
something. That's a normal thing to eat.
Even more than a bear. It is get
more angry. So kitty cat. Yeah.
Yeah. Meanwhile that motherfucker will
kill you. I had a bunch of people saying,
you know,
you shouldn't have killed her loan.
See Mountain lions like I see you dear.
I'm fucking know shit.
Cause if you've seen mountain Lykes lines,
like you seen deer, there'd be no dear.
It's as simple as that. You know,
I don't know what the numbers are,
but there's probably supposed to be like
one mountain line for every 500 deer or
something like that. Yeah, that's right.
And they're sneaky creature. You
know, you're not supposed to say I'm,
they're not like that. Listen, you,
you could go your whole life not seeing
them and they can be around you all the
time. Yeah, definitely. That's a
fact. If you live in the wilderness,
if you live in Montana or you live in
Colorado and you live in the woods,
you might see one every few years,
you might might issue years and
they are fucking everywhere. Yeah.
I'll say prints all the time,
but I'll never say a cat.
Like I've actually never seen a cat in
a wall or set for the one that I hunted.
And um, that's like that story
I was telling you before,
like it was eight and a cough, but they
typically kill a deer every single day.
So it's fucking deer.
The human,
Brian allows us to manage things
in a certain way, you know,
and it's like these biologist support
all this study and research in the,
you know, go on. Okay, you
can hunt males in this area.
So that's all I could hunt where I
was. I could only shoot a male, a male.
Well that's when the dogs come in handy.
So like I've always,
I've never really wanted to hunt with
dogs cause I like to do all the hunting
myself.
But um,
there's a special bond between the
hunter and the dogs when you're hunting,
that's for sure. And it was actually a
really good experience. I really loved it.
But a lot of people frown on using dogs.
But the best way to,
to determine the sex is the dogs.
We'll track it and the line will take
refuge in a tree and then you can have a
look at a genitals and make sure it's
a male was binoculars. Yeah. Yeah.
Or sometimes if they're low enough
you can tell if the human eye,
so the first thing we established was,
well it was a line that I wanted the
lion that had killed that calf was eating
that calf alive. We ended up getting, uh,
getting the ranch to come in and he ended
up putting a calf out of its misery.
It couldn't be saved and a then we put
the dogs back on that mountain lion track
and I chased him about seven miles
and they end up training. We got,
we marched in and hawked into Detroit
and ended up determining that it was a
male. And then, um, I ended up shooting
and it wasn't really good deaf.
It was quick.
But um,
if it was a female would have
had to have left where we were.
Some states aren't like that and counties
aren't like that where it can be male
and female if the population is too high.
What they're trying to do in that part
of Colorado is just keep that mountain
lion population healthy and
how they determined that
was by shooting males only.
That could change next year.
They could have a rise in mountain lion,
a decrease in the mule deer and other
animals. So they might change that again,
but we could only shoot them mail.
So yeah, the problem in America, um,
particularly in California where
they outlawed hunting with dogs,
is that the perception of using
a dog to go after an animal,
the perception is that it's
not fair, but people, I mean,
there's going to be hard for some people,
especially animal lovers to understand,
but that is the only effective way to
hunt for mountain lions because there's no
way you're going to sneak up on them.
You're just not.
You're not going to see that.
That's when numbers start to bloom.
And other animals like meal deer
and stuff started to plummet,
which I've heard a lot that's
happening in California,
is the mule deer population.
She has been decimated because there's
no control on the mountain lions. Well,
they do have control the mountain lions,
but only government employees killed
the mountain lion kill. Ironically,
the same amount of mountain lions they
were killing when they were hunting is
insane.
It's insane.
But instead of people paying money to
do it and getting it ties back into
conservation and getting
the eat the mountain line,
which I know again people like, what are
you talking about eating mountain line.
I'm telling you folks, I haven't eaten
one, but I'm telling you and you said it.
Brunello said it's one of the most
delicious animals he's ever eaten.
All wanted to bring you sound,
but it's actually illegal to
bring it in to California.
Good thing we always abide by the law.
Adam Green Tree and then
one day I'll try it.
So then I've cooked it up and I'm fading
it to Kim and I was cooking chicken as
well just in case her and
the kids didn't like it.
I had chicken on the grill as well and
I said the mountain line first and now
we're eating the mountain lion and
I'm like, what do you think of it?
And she's like, Oh, I've got the
chicken. I'm like, no you don't.
You've got the mountain lion.
And it was delicious. Dude.
It's tender as I felt like it was a
Tice between like chicken and pork or
chicken. And even venison. Like I
found it right in the middle there.
It's delicious.
And I'm not saying everyone should go
out and hunt a mountain line cause you
can't do that.
Right.
But there's certain places that you
can go and get a tag for the benefit of
wildlife and go and hunter mountain line
people who just have a hard time with
the idea that you are somehow or another
helping to control the population by
killing an animal that kills
other animals. Yeah. Yeah.
It's really weird. They would rather
let nature take its course, but what,
so even if like,
like let's go to Africa now,
even if the lion population why
outweighed something and was running it to
extinction, these people would want to
see it back and just let that happen.
And it's like humans have got a Brian
capacity that allows us to study and put
research into an animal that's like
actually what would be more healthier for
the whole eco system would be if
we come in and hunt these animals.
And what we'll do is we'll charge people
a certain tag fee to be able to do
that. And we'll put that back into
conservation, which will help this animal.
And then there's just this beautiful
healthy bowl that keeps turning. Yeah.
For the people that know it, they respect
it and they appreciate it. You know,
people like back country hunters
and anglers and all these different
organizations,
Rocky Mountain Elk Federation,
a lot of different organizations that
they have in the United States that really
appreciate what they're
doing to promote that, that,
that idea here in America.
But people that don't hunt and don't,
don't go into,
I mean it took me years to kind of
wrap my head around it and really truly
understand it and become educated as to
how it works and how wildlife biologists
set these standards and they do it based
on healthy populations and how much
time they spend doing surveys
and analyzing the population,
how important it is to,
you know,
these reports and hunter send
in to wildlife organizations
and the department of
fish and game.
It's really interesting stuff and I'm
not a blanket killer evil because I
understand where those people are
coming from as well. And we needed to,
we need a certain amount of that because
it could go the opposite way where it's
like,
let's just go out and hunt everything,
and it's not the case if something's
not in a good, healthy population.
I'm not interested in hunting and
overall myself. Of course. Yeah.
Now I want to say these animals stay here
for forever. I want my kids, kids, kids,
kids, to be able to see those animals
in good health, healthy population.